[Générique] A travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle, c'est, c'est l'épopée temporelle.
Narrateur : Bonjour chers auditeurs, tu veux écouter les nouvelles aventures d'Iris, Thomas et Eliot?...
...Ah mais j'avais oublié, Eliot les a abandonné et ils se retrouvent aux Etats-Unis dans les années 60 car les robots...
...veulent y modifier le temps. "Quoi exactement?" vous allez me demander... 'J'EN SAIS RIEN': je vous répondrai.
[CRIS ET BRUIT DE PORTAIL]
Le lapin: Vous voilà arrivé.
Thomas: Ouf enfin...
Le lapin: Mets 5 étoiles, faut pas oublier...
Thomas: Des couloirs, des bureaux, c'est bien ça change des trucs trop dangereux.
Le lapin: Ca a l'air calme mais j'ai l'impression que le temps est en train d'être... *argh* je disparais...
... dans la douleur *charabia*
Iris: J'arrive toujours pas à croire qu'Eliot nous aie trahi et soit parti avec l'autre robot là.
Oh mon dieu!
Thomas: Quoi?
Iris: Je viens de réaliser un truc: c'est la première fois qu'on fait une mission que tous les deux.
Thomas: Et Alors? ça te fait peur?
Iris: Moi?! J'ai peur de rien, c'est juste que tu vas en profiter pour me reconquérir...
...et ça va me saouler.
Thomas: Je ne comptais pas faire ça Iris.
Iris: Mais si évidemment, on en a déjà parlé Thomas du passé...
... C'est pas parce qu'on a eu un enfant dans le futur qu'on va finir ensemble.
Thomas: Ok, ok...
... Allons voir si on peut parler à quelqu'un et comprendre ce qui est modifié ici.
Iris: Allons! Tu dis "allons", genre tous les deux quoi, voilà, tu me lies à toi en utilisant la première personne du pluriel...
... T'es vraiment un pervers narcissique.
Fille: Bonjour! Je peux vous aider?
Thomas: euh, bonjour madame.
Fille: Non pas madame, mademoiselle.
Thomas: Bonjour mademoiselle.
Cathy: Cathy!
Thomas: Thomas! Enchanté!
Cathy: Bonjour Thomas...
... Ravis de faire ta connaissance.
Iris: euh, je suis là hein !
Thomas: Pardon !...
... Iris, je te présente Cathy, Cathy je te présente Iris.
Iris: Non mais j'étais là pendant ces dix dernières secondes.
Thomas: Cathy, vous faites quoi ici? Enfin, on est où?
Cathy: Vous êtes dans le M.I.T, le Massachusetts Institute of Technology...
... c'est ici qu'on invente le futur.
Iris: Vous inventez le futur?...
... ça nous intéresse ça, vous travaillez sur quoi?
Cathy: Suivez moi, je vais vous montrer...
...ici on n'a pas souvent de visiteur...
Thomas: du futur...
...Vous inventez du futur, Woh!
Cathy: hop hop, on s'arrête là...
... ici ma collègue "Jenny" travaille sur une voiture amphibie décapotable ...
... N'est-ce pas Jenny?
Jenny: *se noyant*
Cathy: Alors ici Bonnie travaille sur un prototype révolutionnaire.
Thomas: Oh qu'il est mignon le petit chat...
Iris: Beh oui mais pourquoi vous le mettez dans un micro-ondes?
Jenny: Ce micro-onde sert à réchauffer les êtres vivants en toute sécurité...
...Quand il sera terminé bien sûr :p
Iris: C'est vraiment le futur que vous inventez? Non parce que je suis un peu scientifique et je veux pas être impoli mais...
...c'est un peu tout pourrie votre truc
Thomas: Roh Iris!
Cathy: Non elle a raison, elle a raison, on donne tout ce qu'on a mais en ce moment on est pas au top top.
Thomas: Mais non, ne dites pas ça Cathy... Vous par exemple, vous travaillez sur quoi?
Cathy: Un petit projet bof...
...un truc qui marchera sûrement jamais.
Iris: sûrement ouais...
Thomas: Dîtes toujours, ça sera forcément mieux que le micro-onde pour animaux.
Cathy: ça s'appelle: L'Internet.
Iris et Thomas: Quoi?!
Thomas: Vous avez inventé L'internet, Cathy?...
... Mais vous êtes trop forte.
Cathy: Vous en avez entendu parler? C'est gentil ça Thomas.
Iris: Attendez...
... Comment ça se fait qu'on n'ait jamais entendu parler de vous et puis il y'a que des filles ici.
Cathy: Oui!...
... Ici toutes nos inventions sont créés par nous: "les secrétaires" puis quand il y'en a une qui marche...
les ingénieurs mettent leur nom dessus à la fin.
Thomas: Mais c'est horrible.
Cathy: Non, attendez, je ne suis pas idiote non plus. Pour la création d'Internet...
... j'ai réussi à négocier pour avoir trois tickets resto et une place de parking au -2 au lieu du -3 et...
... je peux vous dire, j'ai fait des jalouses ici.
Iris: C'est ça les robots veulent s'en prendre à l'invention d'Internet...
...Cathy vous nous emmenez voir votre prototype?!
Cathy: Ah oui avec plaisir oui oui.
Iris: C'est d'une importance capitale.
Cathy: Je suis toute émoustillée. ...
... Venez on va rentrer dans l'Internet.
Thomas: Mais quel aventure!...
... J'ai l'impression d'être dans le seigneur des anneaux sauf que les nains sont des jolies filles.
Cathy: Thomas? Vous, vous connaissez le seigneur des anneaux? j'adore les œuvres de Tolkien.
Thomas: Evidemment,  Tolkien, c'est la base et aussi (euh) les seuls livres que j'ai lu.
Cathy: Vous savez tout le monde se moque de moi ici quand je parle du seigneur des anneaux...
...je pensais pas trouver quelqu'un qui, qui partage ma passion.
Thomas: Moi non plus, c'est si rare...
... qu'on me comprenne aussi.
Iris: Oh, arrête Thomas...
... Moi aussi je connais le seigneur des anneaux, ce n'est pas si pointu que ça.
Thomas: Ah bon tu connais vraiment?...
... Alors tu connais : "Tom Bombadil" ?
Iris: Tom Bombalquoi? c'est le quel lui déjà? C'est euh...
... Ah, c'est le nain?!
Thomas: Ah, c'était un piège...
... Tom Bombadil n'apparaît que dans les livres, pas dans les films Iris.
... Et visiblement tu ne les a jamais lu contrairement à Cathy et moi.
Iris: Pff non mais attends...
Cathy: Attendez mais de quel film vous parlez là?...
... Nous voilà arrivés, préparez vous à entrer dans l'Internet.
Thomas: *content* Je suis trop excité. ...
... Oh, je crois que j'ai fait un peu pipi.
Cathy: Oui moi aussi, Thomas, on est tellement pareil.
Iris: Vous êtes tellement dégueu oui... Allez on ouvre la porte.
Thomas: Ahhhhhh...
... Ok
Iris: Woh
Thomas: C'est ça Internet. Un gros frigo avec plein de câbles.
Cathy: Attendez je vais vous faire une démonstration...
... Regardez, j'appuie ici...
... et ...
... attention, parce que ça va vous faire un choc.
Iris: ça va être long?
Cathy: Quoi?!
Thomas: Elle dit: ça va être bon?
Iris: Mais non, j'ai pas dis que je m'appelle Leon...
Cathy: Une baie en béton?
Thomas: Moi aussi j'ai mal aux têtons.
Cathy : Ca y'est, regardez ce que ça a imprimé.
Thomas: Juste la lettre 'W'
Cathy: Kelly, ton message, c'était bien la lettre 'W'?
Kelly: Yes!
Cathy: Et voilà!...
... Internet.
Thomas: Ah. D'accord je pensais qu'on allait faire des jeux en VR...
... entrer dans une vidéo porno mais imprimer une lettre c'est bien.
Iris: Oui, très impressionnant. Bon y'a rien qui vous paraît anormal dans cette pièce?...
...Je suis sûr que les deux robots ont fait quelque chose.
Cathy: Franchement non, tout me paraît normal...
... Stop ...
... Vous entendez?
Thomas: Entendre quoi?
Cathy: le bip bip.
Iris: Y'a 15000 bip bip.
Cathy: Mais non,  pas les 'bopbop' ni les "dip dip'...
... Je vous parle du bipbip bizarre
Thomas: Beh oui Iris, suis un peu.
Iris: Thomas, fais pas genre tu...
Thomas: Ah! Une bombe!
Cathy: C'est ça le bip bip merci Thomas!
Thomas: Cathy, sortez d'ici, je vais désamorcer cette bombe.
Cathy: C'est dangereux!
Thomas: Je sais ce que je fais. Attendez dehors...
Cathy: Soyez prudents!
Thomas: Iris, j'ai besoin d'un service...
Iris: Tu veux que je désamorce la bombe et que je fasse croire que c'est toi?
Thomas: Roh, merci!...
... T'es un pote!
Iris: Non mais je ne suis pas ton pote...
Thomas:Ah bon?! T'es quoi alors?
Iris: Beh je suis ton, ta... On s'en fiche! Bon, comment faire?!
Thomas: VITE IRIS!...
... Si seulement Eliot était là.
Iris: Il était là! Et il aidé à poser cette bombe!...
... bon je vois deux fils: un rouge et un bleu. C'est sûrement l'un des deux, mais comment savoir?
Thomas: Je vais voir s'il existe des tutos pour désamorcer une bombe.
Iris: Ok et tu vas voir ces tutos où?...
... Thomas?
Thomas: Beh je vais aller sur... Ah oui, Ok.
Iris: Mais t'es tellement stupide.
Thomas: Stupide? Non, mais toi t'aides pas non plus! Alors que madame est censé être super...
...intelligente. Vas y, fais un truc pour voir.
Iris: J'ai pas a arracher un fil au hasard!
Thomas: Et beh... moi je le fais!
Iris: NON! THOMAS!
Thomas: Voilà c'est fait...
Iris: oh, euh,  ah oui. Et beh oui en effet, mais ça reste complètement STUPIDE!
Thomas: Jamais contente...
Cathy: Thomas, tu as réussi?
Thomas: Oui, c'est bon, Internet est sauvé.
Cathy: Tu es si...
...courageux comme Aragorn.
Thomas: Et toi, si belle et si intelligente comme Gandalf
Cathy: Oh Thomas, tu sais me parler.
Thomas: Et toi, tu me comprends...
...tu sais ton invention est une des plus belles choses qui va m'arriver dans la vie.
Iris: Bien bien bien...
... Thomas, on dit au revoir, on va y'aller.
Thomas: Oui beh c'est bon, deux secondes. T'es relou à me casser mes délires tout le temps comme ça iris...
... T'arrêtes pas de dire qu'on est que des amis, et beh comporte toi en ami et comprend quand je vie un truc important...
... Roh, ce que tu peux être égoïste.
Iris: Bien j'ai compris. Si tu veux rester ici,  y'a pas de problème. Tu as trouvé...
... quelqu'un qui te correspond après tout, j'ai passé mon temps à dire que t'étais inutile...
... immature
Thomas: Moche.
Iris: moche oui.
Thomas: Stupide.
Iris: Oui, stupide aussi. Bon ça va, on va pas tout énumérer non plus...
... je vais pas me plaindre, maintenant tu veux rester.
Cathy: Thomas?...
... Tu veux venir avec moi voir la cafétéria?
Thomas: Tout ce que tu voudras
Le lapin: Oh, je suis vivant! YES!...
... le doc' a bien fait de parier sur vous.
Iris: Y'a plus que moi maintenant.
Le lapin: Hey beh, tout le monde te quitte on dirait...
...faudrait peut-être te remettre en question ma petite chérie.
Thomas: IRIS!!...
... Attends, je viens avec toi
Iris: Ah bon?!...
... Tu veux pas te marier avec ta nouvelle copine la?
Thomas:  Non mais attends...
...C'est pas parce que je croise une fille sympa que j'ai envie de faire ma vie avec.
Iris: Ah! Ok!
Thomas: Et puis à part Tolkien, on partage pas tant de choses que ça...
Cathy: Alors Thomas?! Thomas, tu m'as pas dit...
... C'est bon pour toi dimanche, on va brûler des croix devant la maison des noirs. ...
... ça va être super marrant. Je te prête une manche avec une capuche.
Iris: Ah oui, c'est vrai, on est en 1963...
Thomas: Hmm hmm, bon, on y va?
Le lapin: Le doc' m'a donné votre prochaine destination: Paris!...
...1789, le 14 juillet.
Thomas: Je me demande bien sur quoi on va tomber à cette date
Iris: Beh, Thomas...
Thomas: Quoi?
Iris: Non rien... Reste comme ça...
Le lapin: Re-Temporalisation IMMÉDIATE!
Narrateur: Et voilà, nos héros ont sauvé internet et heureusement parce que sans internet, cette série audio n'aurait jamais existé...
...et Cyprien aurait dû trouver un vrai métier...
...et je n'aurais jamais pu acheter, enfin je veux dire...
...rencontrer ma femme, sur internet. Allez, à bientôt pour la suite de l'épopée temporelle et vive internet!
Cyprien : Merci d'avoir écouté le 6ème épisode de la deuxième saison de l'épopée temporelle et à la semaine prochaine.